what do i do after school I got a
question from one of my youtube viewers
Martin love you guys who wrote in the
say he is graduating school and he
doesn't know what to do next year they
go after art which is something that he
loves but he doesn't see a way to make a
lot of money where does it go through
something more technical where it's
easier to make money he doesn't come
from a wealthy background his family
isn't rich so he's worried about being
able to survive and wanted my advice on
what to do this is a really tough one
Martin but for me I always try to listen
to my heart instead of my head every
time there's a big decision in front of
me the problem with listening to your
head is that your head only understands
the world that currently exists and
you're going to make a logical decision
where your heart will help you make a
new world and a new reality for yourself
and be able to live your dreams that
comes from your heart it doesn't come
from your head you can make a lot of
money as an artist they may come with a
lot of work a lot of sacrifice a lot of
struggle a lot of pain but you can make
a lot of money if you go the technical
room here's two things that are going to
happen to you ok the first off is you're
never going to be great at what you do
you might have a good job you know you
might make a good amount of money but
you're never going to be great you're
never going to be number one in your
field because you're not passionate
about this you don't want to be in
technical school you want to be in a
technical job and you're not going to
bring the energy the the momentum the
creativity the drive everything you need
to be successful you're not going to
bring it full on because you're not
excited about this job and the second
thing that's going to happen is you're
going to be constantly living in regret
you're going to think about it and say
you know what if what if what if I went
this other way with my life what if I
went that path the art route what would
my life look like now you know you may
end up like every other person who hates
their job who's just living for the
weekend making enough to get by that's
how most people live and I really don't
want that for you and I know it's hard
to break out of out of the shell out of
the comfortable out of the norm because
this is what most people this is how
most people live their life when I was
graduating University I had had a really
important choice to make with my my
business I had a company it was a
startup company I was making three
hundred dollars a month nothing right
like can't survive kind of money eating
beans every day for lunch kind of money
nothing and on the other hand I was
being recruited by two of the top
companies in my field where if I wanted
to get a job that's where i was going to
go and they were offering 80 to a
hundred thousand dollars a year starting
salary they were flying me off to New
York putting me up at the Waldorf
Astoria one of the most expensive hotels
in the world flying me around recruiting
me wanted me to work for their business
what is the logical thing to do what is
my head say here's what you should do I
don't come from a rich family I don't
come from a poor family but we were
middle class my parents never gave me
money but what my parents gave me was a
belief in myself and I remember anytime
I had a difficulty in my childhood with
over the school or something I was
trying sports something didn't work out
my parents would always sit me down and
maybe I was crying and they would tell
me Evan you're a cost rlly Carmichael
you can do anything and growing up I
always believed that end up taking that
with me through my business career
and so when I had that decision do I
work on my three hundred dollar-a-month
company or do I work for a company and
make 80-100 k and fly around the world
it took a lot of guts to say I'm gonna
do my business it took a lot of strength
but it just felt right logically and
made no sense you know you look at this
from the outside my friends look at it's
like you're what are you doing you're
crazy how could you turn down this
opportunity there's nothing happening
with your your company what are you
doing and I had to listen to my heart it
just felt like I needed to do this like
I would find a way I had to at least try
did not want to live the rest of my life
wondering what if what if I just stuck
with it and I'm so glad and so grateful
that I didn't go the job route and it
was hard and I suffered and I doubt it
myself and and faced some of the most
you know terrifying and painful
situations in my life getting that
business off the ground but it did work
out and now i have my friends coming
back to me who are graduated school with
and they're saying you know what i hate
my job i'm working 80 to 100 hours a
week I can't do this anymore you know I
never see my my wife or my husband I'm
thinking of starting my own business and
I look at them and I'm like oh my i'm so
glad that i didn't go that route if you
look at when people are dying
the number one thing that they say if
they said I wish my life was different
what do you wish and the number one
thing they say is I wish I taken more
chances I don't want that to be you I
don't want that to be me I don't want to
sit back when I'm on my death bed
looking back in my life and said this
was nothing I didn't I wish I'd taken
more risk-taking more chances believed
in myself more so you're on an
interesting point Martin where you are
right now you know seventeen just
graduating you have the whole wall in
front of you I'm sure you're getting
lots of opinions from people on what to
do the best advice that I can give you
is even though it's scary even though
you don't know how it's going to work
out even though you don't see any
opportunities to make money at it right
now listen to your heart and you'll find
your path believe those are you watching
like the video give it a thumbs up below
let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath you have a question
leave a comment I'll make a video
response and subscribe to the channel if
you want to see more videos like this
thank you so much and I'll see you soon